caminati 10 dimitrios et chirurgien
cardiaque de l'hôpital saint luc en
grèce il était notre invité tout à
l'heure
j'ai pensé c'est assez logique et lui ou
moi on va avec cette élection à la
direction ou des hommes non vaccinés il
n'y aura pas d'élection à mon avis et
les écoulements duras et
il y aura des réflexions le cours en
soirée ça va les emmener tôt dans les
autres confinement plus mal on a vu mais
promet qu'il y aura des restrictions il
faut avoir une description aussi les
jambes section on n'approche pas le taux
de 87% il paraît que c'est assez curieux
pour les taux de taxes nationales sans
raison simple sens unique on parle